may i study the gown who are we wearing
can i tell you who because they're
kind of new
they're in canada
and they are called greta constantine
watch this
constantine is the name of their mothers
the designers moms and they're fabulous
you smell amazing thank you that's my
favorite perfume what is it jessica
clintock
you know all the brands i wish i could
tell people at home how wonderful rita
smells right now
you look gorgeous we're asking everybody
what's one secret about your look or
your getting ready process tonight
my lash almost fell loose
well those are the dilemmas that we
people face i mean you know it's just
awful
when your lashes getting loose
i just didn't know what i was going to
do
it is that incredible acting that has
you nominated everybody celebrating west
side story it's like this incredible act
i i could watch you open a box
that's adorable thank you
how does it feel to be celebrating west
side story
i love it and i just found out that
ariana won
best supporting at the baftas
give her a congrats right to camera
ariana will she see it
ariana
congratulations
well tonight you're nominated in the
same category right is there like did
you talk about that is there friendly
competition
no competition i mean i no
come on you know she's gonna i mean i
know she's gonna get it
so no that's okay hey i'm honored to
have been included in this movie as a
best supporting along with ariana it's
amazing
in fact i remember calling stephen
spielberg saying has this happened
before what do i do he said don't do
anything
he said but
you know i said should i curtail my
appearances he said no
it shows that you support the movie
[Music]